[Music]
oh let me ask you about your character
on the show interesting fascinating to
me uh because
there are
many people have talked about this in
the office because we have a lot of uh
fans of your show that work here and
they um don't do that and they uh
i'll never do that it's a very dirty
thing uh but your
your character's
kind of and his sexuality can be
ambiguous at times
yes yeah
yeah well i think all of our characters
are a little ambiguously
gay yeah you know and i i but i think
that's actually reflective of most
people
all right let me explain no no i just
[Applause]
you got me
listen man listen
i think there's i i think honestly i
think on a scale of one to ten i think
everybody falls somewhere in that range
right of gayness like one being not gay
at all it's a spectrum
there's a total spectrum at one being
not gay at all 10 being like totally 100
percent gay
i think that this entire you do you
think as a person well i can recognize
that a man is handsome and i can go you
know like i see brad pitt in fight club
and i go yeah
nice
come on come on right yeah sure why not
okay
we all did we we we all did you'd be
like a seven or a six no dude oh i'm
sorry no no no no no no i'm sorry
dude
you said nice no no no no no
pushed it up a little bit no at a
certain point at a certain point you
don't you know get married to a
beautiful woman and have a kid you're
like you know you're in the six seven
range where you go
i'm pretty gay yeah i'm pretty gay i'm
gonna go with dudes right but if but you
know that's usually like in the 910
range if you're a six you might you know
you might be like yeah i did something
with a dude in college but i'm still
gonna
i'm still gonna get married to abroad
and you know have a little baby
yeah and describe the baby like this i
don't know he's like that's what it is
you get him and you're like
are you standing him up right a lot
that's probably not a good idea two days
old no no no no they're not supposed to
walk yet not yet it's been two days look
at him
why can't you hold your head up what are
you doing
what's your problem what's your name
flopsy
it's always sunny in philadelphia
obviously a hilarious show airs
thursdays at 10 o'clock p.m on fx
tomorrow night wrapped it up before you
got to his number what are you doing
what are you talking about your number
on the scale oh yeah what's your number
on the scale you said you said of it if
you there was a guy in college is that
what you said yeah a dude in college
that you did some stuff with i'll leave
it vague but where are you on the scale
man are you uh you just answered the
question
yeah
those are some good times yeah baby
the u is 1985.
what were you saying about my television
show i was saying it's always sunny in
philadelphia which is a hilarious show
uh no it is hilarious show airs
thursdays at 10 o'clock p.m on fx watch
that show glenn howerton hilarious and
congratulations